welcome welcome to the economic sciences
price lectures 2016 as a very brief
introduction if you look at introductory
textbooks in in economics they describe
transactions in a very simple way
there's a settler who's producing
something and he sells it and there is a
buyer who pays a price and consumes this
good and that's it that's the
transaction but of course you know that
in reality many transactions are much
more complicated and they are supported
by more or less complicated contracts
for example employment contracts are
typically quite complicated or and final
financial contracts this this picture is
supposed to illustrate what can go wrong
if the contract is not quite well
designed is it self explanatory I think
so I give you a few seconds to figure it
out but but moving on to the to this
this year's laureates Oliver Hart and
Bank Holmstrom they are rewarded for
their contributions to contract theory
and we're going to start alphabetical
order we're going to start with with
Oliver Hart and here are just a few few
stats he was born in London he got his
PhD from Princeton and he's now a
professor of economics at
about University and I would like to
invite professor Hart to come up on
stage and give his prize lecture
[Applause]
well um thank you very much
Tomas let me begin by saying that I am
absolutely thrilled to have been awarded
this prize oh that's no surprise and I'm
delighted to have the opportunity today
to talk about the work that led to it
for me that work started in 1983 the
summer of 1983 when Sanford Grossman and
I asked ourselves the following question
why would one firm ever buy another firm
rather than conduct business with that
firm through a contract in other words
what are the limits of contracts now we
knew that Ronald Coase and Oliver
Williamson among others had written on
this topic but we also knew that their
work was unform alized as economic
theorists our goal was to develop a
formal model of the difference between
arm's length contracting and integration
or a merger purchasing a firm we worked
intensively for 10 days with apologies
to John Reed and here I'm talking about
the American journalist who died in 1920
not the former CEO of Citigroup it was
10 days that shook my world at some
point we realized that the key elements
to understanding the difference are
contractual incompleteness and residual
control or residual decision rights so
to illustrate the ideas consider the
somewhat unfashionable case of a power
plant that net locates next to a coal
mine with the purpose of burning the
coal to make electricity so this is a
real-world example and such
relationships often last for decades
how to manage the relationship one
possibility is for the power plant and
the coal mine to remain as separate
companies and to have an arm's length
long-term contract with each other so
the contract would specify the quantity
quality and price of coal for many years
to come
the problem is that any such contract
will be incomplete events will occur
that the parties could not fully foresee
when they start it out for example
suppose that the power plant needs the
coal to be pure but it is that it is
hard to specify in advance what purity
means given that there are many
potential impurities imagine that 10
years on Ash content is the relevant
impurity and that high ash content coal
is more expensive for the power plant to
burn but cheaper for the coal mine to
produce given that the contract is
incomplete the coal mine may be within
it within its rights under the contract
to supply high ash content coal the
contract simply wasn't explicit enough
to rule that out now the power plant can
of course do something about that it can
try to renegotiate the contract but it
may find that it has to pay the coal
mine a large sum of money to persuade it
to switch from the cheap high ash
content coal to the more expensive low
ash content core in other words the coal
mine may have the power plant over a
barrel that may not be the best word to
use in this context because I don't
think we normally think of barrels of
coal we normally think of barrels of oil
but you you get the idea the point is
that the coal mine is in a very strong
position because the power plant has a
very poor alternative it's located ok
today this coal mine and to go to get
coal from anywhere else we
be very expensive so economists call
this the holdup problem it occurs when
one party party is very dependent on
another party party B and then party B
may have the does have the ability in
principle to to behave in a very
opportunistic way and to force party a
to pay a great deal to get what it wants
from party B okay so that the idea is
that there's this coal mine that is
located next to the power plant and has
this incomplete contract will anticipate
that sorry did I say that I may say that
the wrong way around the power plant you
have to keep these two things clear and
I'm at the power plant located next to
the coal mine realize is that it may be
held up by the coal mine later on and
that may make it reluctant to become
totally dependent on the coal mine for
its source of of coal it may be
reluctant to locate right next to it so
it's worth going into a little more
detail about the source of this holdout
power grossman and I argued that it
arises because the owner of the coal
mine has residual rights of control over
the mine the right to decide on uses of
the coal mine about which the contract
is silent and because the contract is
incomplete
there will be a lot of things it's
silent about so in this case the key
residual right of control is the
decision about which what kind of coal
to mine so the point is that because the
coal mine is a separate entity the owner
of the coal mine can decide whether to
mine the high ash content coal or the
low ash content call and the power plant
will have to pay the owner to do
something other than what the the owner
naturally wants okay so is there
anything the power plant can do to avoid
this holdup situation
short of writing a better contract a
more complete contract one thing it
could do is to buy the coal mine in
advance that way the power plant as
owner of the coal mine will have the key
residual control right so now the power
plant as owner of the coal mine can
decide what kind of code to take out of
the mine so the coal mine can no longer
extract a high price by threatening to
produce high ash content coal the power
plant can order the coal mine manager to
mine low ash content coal and if the
coal mine manager for some reason is
particularly enthusiastic about high ash
content coal and is becoming stubborn
about that the power plant can simply
fire or sack the coal mine manager and
replace the manager with somebody else
the key point is they still have access
to the mine because it belongs to them
so one result of this is that the power
plant may now be more willing to be to
become completely dependent on the coal
mine because it's no longer worried
about being taken advantage of and this
is the benefit of integration
integration here meaning the purchase of
the coal mine by the power plant but and
this is very important there is also a
cost of integration because the manager
of the coal mine who say previously
owned the mine and now they come simply
an employee of the power plant is going
to find himself more vulnerable he loses
power and so he becomes speaking he has
fewer residual control rights and he
becomes more vulnerable for example
suppose that this manager has an idea
about how to mine coal more efficiently
if the manager owns the coal mine he can
be confident about reaping the returns
of this idea from this idea because the
costs will go down profits will go up
and as owner he will he will be able to
pocket
those extra profits but if he's merely
an employee his position is much less
secure for example a power plant could
say when he produces this good idea for
making things more efficient the power
plant owner could say well thank you
very much but now that I have your idea
I don't need you anymore
I can implement it and get the returns
myself and anticipating this the manager
when he becomes an employee has a lower
incentive to have ideas to innovate
bottom line integration has costs as
well as benefits and you have to balance
the two now in a 1990 paper with John
Moore I generalize the analysis to the
case of many assets and workers in my
example there were just two assets and
and two managers but we generalize the
analysis of the case of many assets and
many people and we also considered more
complicated ownership structures not
just whether I owned the mine or you
owned the mine but various forms of
joint or common ownership there are two
main differences from the previous
literature that I want to highlight the
first is that the analysis is more
formal now unfortunately you can't see
that at all today because I've just used
words but let me assure you you can
translate this into form of the kind of
formal models that economists like and
indeed you know it was only by doing
that that we got the words right the
ideas right and but you'll have to wait
for the written lecture to see how that
is done the other point is that the
focus is on in this theory is on the
control over physical or more generally
non human assets rather than authority
or control over people so just to give
you a sense of that ownership at the
coal mine would not yield much to the
power plant
if the manager of the coal mine is
indispensable if his human capital is
essential for making things work
because then the this manager would
still be able to hold up the power plant
even if the power plant owns the coal
mine because the manager can just say I
will I refuse to produce low ash content
coal unless you pay me a huge amount and
the point is what can the power plant to
do if this guy is the only person in the
world who can actually figure out how to
get the coal out of the mine so it's
important for the story that human
capital is somewhat replaceable okay
well as well as helping us to understand
mergers this approach has other
applications one is to corporate finance
so in the electricity call example I
want to you to still think about this
but I that case but except I want you to
replace the power plant by a financial
investor that is let's consider the case
where the coal mine needs money to
expand or modernize and it doesn't have
the money itself so it approaches
someone with deep pockets an investor
how does it get the investor to agree to
put up this money well it has obviously
has to be provide some sort of assurance
that the investor is going to get a
return and one way can do that is by
promising some share a future profit but
this may not be enough the problem is
that the contract between the skipper no
that's right I suppose the the contract
between the investor and the coal mine
is likely to be incomplete
for the same kinds of reasons as I
mentioned before difficulty of
anticipating the future the investor
will therefore be worried about
opportunistic behavior which is similar
to hold up by the manager of the coal
mine for example the manager of the coal
mine could instead of you know I
promised you a profit share good profit
share but at what I could do is instead
of paying out profits to you as you
want I could divert the earnings I could
pay myself a large salary instead of
paying out profits or I could take those
profits and reinvest them in activities
that you might not approve of rather
than paying you back so even though I
promised you a good share of the profits
this may not be enough to give you
confidence that you're going to get a
return on your investment what can be
done well one way to protect the
investor against opportunism is by
giving her residual control rights or
votes for example the investor could
become remember we have this investor in
the coal mine that's modernizing the
investor could become the owner of the
coal mine rather than having an
arm's-length contract with the coal mine
and this would allow the investor to
intervene to stop opportunistic behavior
you know before it happened for example
the investor could control the managers
salary could say no you're not going to
get a raise this year or the investor
could even replace the manager but as
we've seen there can be a downside for
the manager of the coal mine if control
rights are given to the investor the
managers incentive to have ideas may be
reduced if the investor has controlled
just as in the case of the coal mine if
the power plant has control so in a
paper written in 1989 and published in
1998 John Moore and I showed that under
under some assumptions the optimal way
of balancing these things the desire to
persuade the investor that they're going
to break even on their investment or
make a decent return on investment but
at the same time the desire to give the
manager an incentive to have ideas and
all the nice things that go with when
the manager has control rights that the
the best way to balance that can be for
the contract to be a debt contract
and what that means in particular here
is that the coal mine promises to make a
fixed stream of payments to the investor
as long as these payments are made the
manager of the coal mine remains in
charge so the manager retains control as
long as she's making the payments I
think it's a he actually I think the
managers are he and the investors are
she Oh was go confused about that but
anyway if if a payment is not made
control shifts to the investor and the
investor can then decide whether to
replace the manager or sell the mine or
do various other things okay so this
what's good about this is that remember
the problems that I talked about the
managers or Purdue opportunism was
paying in self a very high salary or
reinvesting earnings well you know he's
got a sort of tight budget constraint if
he doesn't make payments as promised to
the investor he's going to be in trouble
he's going to lose control so that's
going to give him an incentive to behave
less opportunistically debt contracts
are of course ubiquitous and the
analysis I think helps to explain why
they are used it also casts light on the
importance of collateral the investor is
better protected if the physical assets
of the mine are important relative to
the managers human capital because in
this case the invest is not worried
about being held up by the manager
because if the manager is difficult the
investor can replace again replace the
manager and you know the physical assets
themselves are very valuable in the
hands that say of another manager or or
liquidated or whatever sold off so in a
case like that where the physical assets
are important relative to the managers
human capital it will be quite easy for
the coal mine to borrow quite a lot in
contrast and this is similar to the
point I made earlier if the managers
human capital is terribly important then
of course the investor no
well yes I can seize the physical assets
if a debt payment isn't made but what
use is that to me because it's the
managers managers human capital is it
that is essential so in that case the
investor will be more reluctant to lend
so the coalmine won't be able to borrow
so much the analysis can also tell us
about the maturity of debt contracts so
if the physical assets are not only
valuable relative to the human capital
but also depreciate quite slowly then
the investor will be comfortable with a
long-term debt contract because he's the
investigator she's protected right she's
protected because if the manager is
difficult she can always seize those
assets and they're still worth a lot
even several years into the future on in
contrast if the assets depreciate very
fast then the investor will only be
protected if we have a short-term debt
contract so empirical support for these
ideas is there fortunately it exists in
the work of Ben Melick
among others okay so that's one
application to understand the balance of
control in financial contracting and
actually I would like to mention also
the work of agonal and Bolton on this
topic where I had a slide on this but I
got very nervous about time and so I my
apologies to them and to some very fine
empirical work by Kaplan & Stromberg
that'll have to wait till the written
lecture ok a second application how am i
doing by the way
ten minutes oh that's great ok a second
application is to public versus private
ownership and I investigated this in the
1997 paper with Andrey Schleifer and
Robert Vishnu so I want you now to
replace the PowerPoint power plant by
the government okay so instead of having
the power plant now we have the
government
and insert the comb having the coalmine
let us have a prison so the situation
now is the government wants prison
services okay people are going to be in
the fridge in the prison incarcerated
perhaps we don't want them to be treated
too badly and so the government has an
interest in getting the right treatment
of the prisoners and this is like the
power plant wanting the right kind of
coal but just as in that earlier example
there are two ways of organizing this
transaction the government can contract
with a private company to provide the
prison services to run the prison maybe
even to build and run the prison that's
one way of doing it the other way of
doing it is that the government can own
and control the prison and then the
people who work in the prison the warden
and the guards and so on will be
government employees that's like the
power plant buying the coal mine so
which is better
well again it boils down to contractual
incompleteness and the allocation of
residual control rights if the prison is
privately run then there's going to be
this contract with the with the private
company to look after the prisoners but
any such contract is going to be
incomplete and that means that the
prison company later on may find a way
consistent with the contract to save
money at the expense of quality which is
undesirable for the government and
society for example the company might
find a way to hire cheaper but less
qualified less well trained guards okay
so this is something which is good for
their bottom line but not so good for
society because these guards may not be
very good at dealing with violent
situations that might arise in the
prison so this kind of action by the
private company is analogous to the
coalmine choosing to mine high ash
content coal when the power company
would prefer low ash content coal so
this is something if the government owns
the prison it can stop this happening if
the warden shows some inclination to
hire these less well trained guards the
government can say no you are not
allowed to do that because that's our
decision we have the residual control
right on the other hand a privately run
prison might have a greater incentive to
innovate to be to be more efficient and
to innovate actually to be more
efficient in terms of reducing costs but
also to innovate say by coming up with
socially valuable rehabilitation
programs so this is something where the
incentives may be greater in the private
case than in the public case for the
same reason that I argued that the
manager of the coal mine might not have
incentives to innovate to have ideas if
he becomes an employee of the power
plant rather than rather than owning the
coal mine himself okay so which which
effect is more important will determine
someone is a you know the benefit of the
government being able to intervene and
stop these Puli train guards being hired
that's a plus of government ownership
but on the other hand the stifling of
innovation or efficiency is a minus of
government ownership so which effect is
more important will determine whether
public or private ownership is better in
our 1997 paper we argued that the first
effect is likely to dominate the second
in the case of maximum-security prisons
where the quality of the guards is
particularly important so here dealing
with violent situations is particularly
important and so we've we thought having
the government with the residual control
rights would be a good thing and so
public provision would be better but
there of course other cases where the
trade-off goes the other way and
privatization is good and garbage
collection rubbish collection we thought
as a leading case of that I think one
thing which is perhaps
useful about the analysis is that it
shows that economics rather than
politics can guide us with respect to
the public-private choice
this is often this often ends up being
an ideological matter when you hear
people arguing about it but what this
says is no we should really think about
it in economic efficiency terms Oh at
least that's a useful perspective okay
well I think I'm close to the end so let
me just say if I had more time I would
talk about my recent work over the last
10 years or so where I've introduced
behavioral elements in particular our
concern by the contracting parties for a
reasonable or fair outcome to understand
at a deeper level why contracts are
incomplete don't have time for that
which is a pity I would also talk about
two legal cases I was involved in where
I used I used the work I've described as
an expert witness for the US government
this will all be so this is all and
holding this back to give you an
incentive to read the the lecture the
written nature when it is finally
available let me end then by just
acknowledging some of my co-authors in
this endeavor so here you have it looks
as if my co-author is the Continental
Divide or maybe it's that mountain over
there but if you look very carefully you
will see someone in the middle and that
is Sandford Grossman
another important collaborator who can
be seen much more clearly is John Moore
on the prison's paper my author
co-authors were Andrew Slifer and and
robert vishnu and then on the behavioral
work which I haven't had time to talk
about that also that was theoretical but
I also carried out some experiments lab
experiments at some point with the help
of Christian Zender and Ernst fair now I
know that I had another notable
co-author but and this must be age I
just cannot remember his name can you
help me all right on that note I think I
will end thank you
[Applause]